to you the prime minister is promising
to focus on levelling up along with
extra funding for public transport and
women's safety at the start of the
conservative party conference boris
johnson said the government must take
what he called big bold decisions to
rebuild after the pandemic but some tory
back benches are warning about a cost of
living crisis the observer says mps are
concerned that working families will be
hit by increased taxes and benefit cuts
a warning that this report from our
political correspondent joe pine
contains flash photography from the
start
he is juggling multiple crises
is the country in crisis prime minister
and at conservative party conference in
the coming days expect new policies to
try and tackle them
there will be tougher sentences for
protesters like insulate britain who
block motorways those involved face six
months in jail and unlimited fines
we know that insulate britain get
criticism for their tactics
you don't have to be
in favor or against their tactics to
realize that their fundamental point
about the need to insulate our houses
and to get them to be zero carbon is
correct
after criticism of how the police deal
with violence against women following
the murder of sarah everard 25 million
pounds has been earmarked for projects
to help make streets safer 25 million
pounds is peanuts and government money
what i'm asking and so many others are
asking is that this is put on the same
level as as
fighting terrorism
as fighting other types of crime this
affects and
debilitates
50 of the population when is the
government going to wake up and the pm
has also hinted at an announcement on
east west rail links in the north of
england i'll be saying a bit more about
northern powerhouse rail in the course
of the next few days
but but believe me you can make such a
difference to people's lives with uh
with better quality
transport infrastructure
better skills and and better access to
basic things like broadband
boris johnson arrives here in manchester
with a new cabinet an opinion poll lead
a big commons majority and no internal
challenger prime ministers are rarely in
positions of such strength he'll want to
savour it but mr johnson knows he'll
have to work hard if it's to last and
that means focusing on his post-brexit
post-covert domestic policy
expect endless mentions of levelling up
in the coming days joe pike sky news
manchester
let's talk to our political
correspondent kate mccann who's in
manchester for us this morning the prime
minister may be in a very strong
position he may be looking at leveling
up but with the cost of living crisis i
mean that is going to be a a huge
challenge to overcome a conference isn't
it
well look i think that's the difficult
balance that boris johnson has to strike
with the country but actually when it
comes to conference he's probably in
quite a good position his party
generally is quite buoyant he's doing
well in the polls as you saw from joe's
film there there are some questions
among conservative mps about things like
the decision not to keep the 20-pound
uplift of universal credit although the
chancellor has put some financial help
into local councils to try and mitigate
the effect of that but really the bigger
problem is that boris johnson says the
economy is changing we're going through
a shift post covered and also
post-brexit and he believes that
politically lots of people will agree
with what's happening that actually the
country needs to move to a higher wage
economy and that's why you're seeing
boris johnson saying things like you
know i'm not going to increase the
number of european nationals who come
over here to work on lorries beyond what
we immediately need because what he
wants to happen is for uk nationals to
be employed instead and for standards to
go up but there will be a bit of a gap
that needs to be bridged between
potentially that new kind of economy if
the prime minister can pull it off and
what we are used to seeing at the moment
and that tricky period is what lots of
conservative mps are worried about they
are concerned about the cost of energy
bills about the fact that it's still
quite difficult to find fuel to put in
your car particularly in the south of
the country and what that all means for
people in the run-up to christmas will
we all feel it when it comes to shopping
for christmas presents and christmas
food for example those are the things
that are immediate
immediately playing on boris johnson's
mind but i think in terms of the
long-term projection actually what lots
of mps want to hear from him here is how
to do leveling up what build back better
really means in practice and we've seen
some of that we've seen some
announcements potentially over this
conference on northern rail that could
make a big difference up here for
example but i think there are lots of
mps who want now a tangible policy to
deliver on some of those election
slogans that boris johnson made in 2019
because remember this is the first
conference since he won that election so
it's going to be an interesting
atmosphere here and of course conference
starts today and it'll be happening in
manchester until wednesday so we'll be
bringing you all the latest throughout
the day from here
okay kate thank you well trevor phillips
will be live at conference as well this
morning he'll going to be talking to the
party's chair oliver dowden but also the
mayor of greater manchester labour's
andy burnham that all starts at half
past eight
drivers in eastern and southern england
are reported to be experiencing ongoing
shortages as the fuel crisis continues
military personnel are due to start
making deliveries from tomorrow the
government have said this is just a
precaution and i've asked people to go
about their business as usual
the prime minister of new zealand
jacinda adern says all passengers on
international flights will need to be
fully vaccinated when travel rules are
eventually relaxed it comes as the
lockdown has been extended across parts
of the country after two new cases of
the delta variant were identified
we ask that those who can work from home
do work from home
we intend at this stage for these level
three restrictions to apply for the next
five days i can tell you that across new
zealand uh 79 of eligible new zealanders
have had their first dose in auckland uh
roughly 83 and a half percent have had
their first dose it is the minority
we need though all new zealanders not
just those dealing in freight to be
vaccinated
a 15 year old girl has died from covid
on the day she was due to get her jab
after getting a positive pcr test four
days earlier georgia halliday was being
treated at the queen alexandra hospital
in portsmouth
well there have been 30 301 new cases of
coronavirus in the last 24 hours
and 121 people more people have died
after contracting the disease it takes
the total number of people who've died
within 28 days of a positive test to 136
910
nearly 38 000 first doses of a vaccine
that were given in the last day and
nearly 34 000 second doses were given
nearly 45 million people are now fully
vaccinated
military housing charities claim afghan
and iraqi war veterans living in
supported housing are in danger of
losing their mental health support for
organizations who provide more than 500
beds to homeless veterans say the
chancellor needs to provide a further 5
million pounds in funding our north of
england correspondent gerard tubb
reports
so basically it's all about
knowing how to turn the world
when dave karan left the army three
years ago he had to rely on friends to
put him up now he's in supported housing
at the beacon at cataract garrison they
found him a role teaching woodwork
and give him and other veterans the
support they need
and it's like another stepping stone for
them to
move up from
so you come in
whatever support you want
so they will
find ways it means to cater for your
needs
morning
can i get a coffee please of course paul
chadwick is another veteran helped by
the beacon which has now run out of
funding for its specialist support
services
following a breakdown he credits them
with saving his life my belief is to
have one of these in every town
really should because it's helped me a
lot i'm now independent living now but
it's all thanks to the people that are
here
and i encourage you to do a lot of
different things all the time
the housing association behind the
beacon along with the three other major
providers of supported housing for
veterans
is calling on the government to commit
five and a half million pounds to their
services over the next two years or they
say see more homelessness and more lives
lost
i think that's one of our biggest
concerns um is the fact that veterans
are reluctant to engage in mainstream
services
and as our services disappear veterans
may well be in the position of needing
to choose between engaging in a
mainstream um homelessness service or
not engaging at all and the worry is
that far too many veterans will choose
not to engage at all
in a statement the government told us we
have announced a further five million
pounds of support for the military
charity sector veterans can also receive
preferential access to social housing we
are in contact with the charity to
understand their concerns
dave and the other veterans who've been
helped by the beacon told us they want
it to continue and if it can't they
don't know where else to turn
gerard tub sky news patrick garrison
the leaders of the three devolved
nations have called on the government to
retain the 20 pounds uplift to universal
credit set to be cut this week amid
fears of a cost of living crisis that
could be worsened by that reduction and
as the conservative party conference
kicks off there are reports some tory
back benches are concerned with how the
cup will affect communities in seats the
party won from labor back in 2019. well
let's talk to
lucy bannister from the joseph rowntree
foundation good to see you this morning
i mean as the ministers would tell us
that this was only ever intended to be a
temporary measure
yes thank you well it's it seems so
clear that on wednesday at the
government
where it was the prime minister will be
facing uh speaking to conservative party
conference millions of families will be
about to face the biggest ever overnight
cut to social security and yes this was
originally seen as a temporary increase
but it now been in place for 18 months
and most people who are currently on
universal credit have only known the
rate at its current level and when the
chancellor implemented this increase he
said it was to strengthen the safety net
that was needed because in the years
leading up to the crisis
um the
years of cuts and freezes to the level
of support available
had um meant that it was no longer able
to effectively support families or give
them the stability they needed to
support their lives and so this 20
pounds was a fundamental um crucial um a
strengthening of the level of support
available and has been a lifeline to
families and many people have been
warning the government uh that taking
this away now uh will be a huge mistake
um and will undermine the adequacy of
our social security system but yet they
seem to be pressing ahead anyway despite
warnings from their own mps and this
means that unfortunately the government
seems to be abandoning millions to
hunger and hardship with its eyes wide
open
i mean to be fair although there is a
a recognition
from the chancellor that this is going
to cause problems he has put in in place
a 500 million pound scheme it will be
administered by local councils but that
is the the household fund which is meant
to mitigate this and support those who
are worst off
yes so i think the fact that the
government is even implementing that
shows a level of concern within
government about uh the crisis facing
families of winter and beyond but what
we're talking about there is a
pot of funding for local authorities to
give to families on a discretionary
basis generally it's one-off grants to
help people in real emergency situations
like it for fridge breaks what we're
talking about um here is a cost of
living crisis um on wednesday bills are
not suddenly going to be 87 pounds a
month cheaper for families in fact
they're going to be getting higher
energy bills are rising food costs are
rising and so um that just doesn't match
up what families need is a strong
adequate social security system to give
them the security and stability when
they need it
they don't you know one-off grant isn't
going to help with that that was a good
thing to do but ultimately it's just
simply not enough um families five and a
half million families are losing 20
pounds a week this will not stretch
anywhere near far enough when the prime
minister you talk about his speech on
wednesday at the time when this uplift
is is going to stop but he's going to
say that his priorities and these big
bold steps that the government needs to
take are going to involve social care
tackling crime and supporting jobs now
in terms of social care and and
supporting jobs i mean they
they're sort of long-term solutions for
this if you can get more people into
work and out of poverty then that's
that's going to make a significant
difference isn't it
yes i think it's um it's fantastic that
the government has such commitment to
getting people um into work and into
better paid jobs um and i think that is
um
no choice
it's a false idea to create this idea of
a choice um between getting people into
work and an adequate social security
system
we need both um universal credit
supports families who are unable to work
it supports families looking for work
and it supports those who are already in
work or learn low paid or insecure jobs
if the is there a government's
plan for jobs if the plan for leveling
up is successful then they will um
automatically see the welfare bill full
um as people and improve their lives
whereas if they go ahead with this cut
they will just be taking money out of
the pockets of low-income workers and
that's why so many of its own mps are
questioning how on earth this cut can be
in line with this the government's own
agenda on leveling up i think it's
really important that to recognize that
yes there are difficult choices facing
government the treasury's got lots of
tools at its disposal
into how it would
pay for this
um but by taking that money away from
people it can't see that as a direct
saving um it it's taking money out of
local economies out of the pockets of um
people in communities and um the cost of
poverty which will revise as a result of
this cut
always comes up elsewhere um and so it's
going to work as a direct um
counter to the government's agenda if it
wants to improve the lives of people
across the country
lucy bannister really good to talk to
you this morning thank you
okay let's have a look at the weather
for you and low pressure to the north of
scotland is bringing some heavy rain and
gales for the northern isles a risk of
ferry disruption actually in those areas
this morning every ev any remaining rain
over east anglia and the southeast will
clear cloud will fill and break so for
many central and eastern parts a bright
start a bit chilly though showers in the
west will break out more widely as the
day goes on some heavy with hail and
thunder
but they should move through quite
quickly to blustery winds temperatures
sort of 12 to 17 celsius
now the london marathon returns today
after numerous covid related days the
last time the race the full race took
place was april 2019 only professionals
were allowed to compete last year and
they didn't actually do the course as
such today we'll see
what 40 50 000 people take part in that
iconic 26.2
mile event and the weather should be all
right
if you're a late runner a slow runner
who cares as long as you enjoy yourself
and roast plenty of money then you might
catch a little bit of rain later on
now after launching the uk's first black
children's magazine selena boyd is now
delving into the world of children's
books and she's using her debut to teach
black girls and boys to embrace their
natural hair and she joins us now good
to see you this morning selena and
what always astounds people like me
because obviously
you know i i don't necessarily
understand it all is but it is why there
has been this move for for black i mean
particularly black girls to to try and
change their natural hair why has there
been that pressure
well i can only speak for when i was
younger i wanted to have straighter hair
a lot of the girls i went to secondary
school with had relaxed straight hair
so i used to put a chemical in my hair
which wasn't particularly good for it
and now i'm just excited about the
movement that's happening right now that
children are embracing their natural
hair and that's why it was so important
to do this fantastic book which just
shows them the different styles that
they can do and that they don't really
resort to hair relaxers and things like
that that can really damage and and not
it's not very good for your hair at all
no i mean is it right that your hair got
a bit damaged by using the relaxers yeah
so that's why i just don't want um the
next generation to evenly
know about hair relaxers i want them to
just embrace their beautiful hair and
you know this is just a little movement
that i'm doing there's bigger movements
like world afro day i mean as well lakia
lee she does project embrace where we
see afro hair on billboards there's been
a bigger movement before i did the hair
book and i'm just really excited about
about what's about to take place because
so many people want this book which is
incredible
i mean the nice thing is when you see
them in some of the some of the stuff
we're looking at from from the book now
or the magazines now i mean it's just
like
you can do so much with it why
why not embrace that it's very difficult
to understand why there has been this
pressure
i think now we are embracing our head
it's a fantastic time um and that's why
i just wanted to do the book because
it's never been done before i mean when
i was given the title coco girl awesome
hair i actually googled awesome hair and
our textured hair didn't come up in
google but now the book does so it's an
exciting time and in the back of the
book you've got all these children that
have now embraced their hair and i wish
that i was around this time as a
youngster because it's incredible we're
seeing representation and we're seeing
children just love who they are you know
my daughter had a difficult time at
first she didn't like her hair but we've
explored different things that she can
do with it and she absolutely can't put
this book down so i want a lot of
children to just embrace who they are
we've also got a coco kids fest coming
up on october the 24th at dulledge
college where children again will be
exploring what they can do with their
hair
one of our main sponsors are
afrocentrics
and there are the first black um
brand that i saw on tv with an advert
you know hair brand so it's just an
incredible movement that's happening
right now i mean you talk about children
wanting to do this which is fair enough
but that's only half the battle isn't it
what about
parents and and parental expectations
yeah well you know what i've
especially doing the magazine
parents are constantly just saying wow i
love the the afro hairstyles that you
put in the magazine um also parents that
have different textured hair to their
children have you know thanked me and
said look since doing your magazine
because we did a hair special i've been
trying out new hairstyles on my child i
would normally send my child to the
hairdressers because they've got
different hair texture to me and i've
never really done their hair so
it's incredible now that we've got this
book
and that they can also try these
incredible styles as well but also read
about our history so you just showed the
band who knocks on the screen you know
bantu as a word need means people and we
find out in the book what tribe in
africa the bantu knots come from so
there's just a wealth of information and
most parents are embracing it do you
know i was just looking at one of the
pictures we showed there was a girl with
sort of sort of hair at the front and oh
oh there you go on the top right sort of
hair at the front and back and what have
you
do you know what strikes me is i can
imagine some schools and i may be wrong
but some schools turning around and
saying oh we don't know if that's an
appropriate hairstyle for our schools i
mean how
how
is there that sort of level of i mean
you could call it institutionalized
racism in an extent where people don't
want to accept sort of
afro hair as as part of of what is
acceptable in schools i mean
is that starting to change now it is
starting to change you've got incredible
movements like the halo code um and they
are doing so many things world afro day
michelle de leon goes into school she
does assemblies on world afroday and she
literally is campaigning for there to be
that change i remember when my daughter
was picking up from school i did a
beautiful hairstyle on her hair for a
picture day and as she's walking through
the crowd to come and meet me after
school somebody with different hair to
her said what a funny hairstyle i thank
god my daughter didn't hear that and so
that's why i'm even more determined to
have books like this schools are some
you know want this book and it's
incredibly important to have books like
this so that you know it's not about
that's a funny hairstyle but that is our
hair we have beautiful hair and i'm so
glad this movement is happening where
children are embracing their hair and
it's making them more confident and you
know when you're more confident you can
thrive um our hair is our history and
our legacy and we are so
happy to just be you know sporting these
fabulous hairstyles yeah and celebrating
it absolutely selena really good to talk
to you thank you
thank you
well black history month will be a
feature of our coverage throughout
october this year's theme is proud to be
focusing on celebrating being black or
brown and showing the pride people have
in their heritage and culture
now as we were saying earlier on the
london marathon returns today after the
pandemic and milano veselynovic has
cheated and gone straight to the finish
line it's very unfair milan i mean it's
going to be quite an event today isn't
it
i'm just here for the win stephen but
yes it is going to be so exciting it's
going to be the biggest marathon stage
anywhere in the world at any time 40 000
participants will do that iconic route
from southeast london to central london
the mall where i am to that finish line
right behind me but if 40 000 further
people from across the world will also
join in virtually and log their results
on the london marathon app and it's a
resurgence for the race the first time
in two years it's been held in 2020 it
was just for the elite runners they were
running in a loop and james's park
around the corner but this year it's
going to be the full experienced people
coming running together but not all of
them together the quirk of this year is
that start times have been staggered
based on people's speeds basically they
supply their predicted finish time and
then they've been grouped in waves and
have been given different stagger times
based on their speed it's basically
still curved precautions to make sure
that not everyone is running in a group
participants will also have to supply a
lateral flow test and all the
international elite athletes will be
tested every single day up to marathon
day but everyone here really looking
forward to it
okay melania we'll catch up with you
later thank you
now he's a was an amateur street artist
now turned professional who counts the
obamas and the late great comic book
legend stan lee amongst his fans known
as mr brainwash thierry guetta pays
tribute to artists like banksy and
damien hurst by reproducing their work
he's been talking to our arts and
entertainment correspondent
katie spencer
he's the shopkeeper who found fame in
banksy's documentary exit through the
gift shop this guy tried to make a
documentary about me but he was
actually a lot more interesting than i
am the oscar-nominated film catapulting
him from used clothing store owner to
pop artist who sold millions in art
you know 12 years later
i can meet some people in the street and
says oh my god i just saw the movie
yesterday
you know and i'm like 12 years ago and
you just keep going and keep going
now under the pseudonym mr brainwash
thierry getter can count celebrity fans
like the obamas rihanna the beckhams and
the head of the catholic church i went
to see the pope once
abroad him her life is beautiful
you know
and
took a picture with him holding the life
is beautiful and i said and it's very
funny because i call it
the pope art
pop art
you know me and him
the artist is in london to launch a new
mural at the city's redeveloped
battersea power station and his
exhibition at clarendon fine art
like early work
that i start to let go
there is no doubting mr brainwash's
success but he has divided the art world
for many reasons one is perhaps
reproducing artists like damian hurst
jeff coons and of course banksy in his
work
you see that's that's what it is
you know you can see you influence you
you
kind of
honor them in the same way
because there is some pieces that you
cannot get
once just a part of banksy's art the man
formerly known as thierry is now a fidi
artiste in his own right
life is beautiful
katie spencer sky news
well the weather isn't beautiful sadly
staying unsettled for the next few days
bit quieter from midweek though this
morning then breezy and chilly for many
central and eastern parts to kick off
with there'll be rain over east anglia
and the far southeast that will clear
whilst rain and strong winds will
continue to affect the northern isles
there is the risk of some ferry
disruption around shetland actually if
you're up at that end blustery showers
in the west will become more frequent
and widespread blowing inland through
the day now the london marathon should
be okay fine start but if you're a late
runner a slow runner then doesn't matter
as long as you have fun but you may
catch a bit of a late shower
now the temperatures are going to range
from the low to mid teens but they're
all going to be offset by the brisk
south westerly wind showers going to
merge together so some longer spells of
rain over scotland for a time elsewhere
they'll die back to the north and west
by the end of the day
now overnight tonight showers will
travel through southernmost counties so
east anglia and the southeast may be
pretty wet by the morning but otherwise
tomorrow should be another day of
sunshine and showers
stay with us here on sky news breakfast
still to come for you we'll take you
through the sunday papers with appiah
adam and thomas copeland
[Music]
[Applause]
this monastery is under the protection
of russian peacekeepers
i'm diana magne and i'm sky's russia
correspondent based here in moscow
they can't arrest everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
did you know that driving us to school
creates extra toxic air at drop-off and
pick-up times
[Music]
central and eastern parts of the country
will have a mostly fine if rather chilly
start to the day but showers already
over western parts will become more
frequent more widespread as the day goes
on and some of those will make their way
inland blown in on a blustery
southwesterly wind
temperatures will reach the low to mid
teens for many a high of around 17
celsius that's 63 degrees fahrenheit but
of course it will feel cooler in that
rather blustery wind needless to say
these rather tempestuous conditions will
lead to a low air pollution count
everywhere
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
let's take you through the papers then
with the journalists after adam and
thomas copeland good to see you both
again this morning um now let's start
with the independent uh affair looking
at uh the fuel crisis
uh lord goldsmith telling us it's a good
lesson on
sort of getting hold of electric cars
and things i mean you have to say
i mean it has crossed my mind that i
thought people with an electric car must
feel quite smug at the moment
oh absolutely it crossed my mind too so
zach goldsmith here saying that the
petrol crisis is a good lesson on the
need to end our dependence on fossil
fuels and accelerate the switch to
electric vehicles so he was um
dismissing fears that perhaps uh this
petrol crisis could force people to
think the other way and i have to agree
with with him shockingly and with you
steven that i think people would think
the opposite that actually this is a
good lesson and why we need to switch to
cleaner vehicles electric vehicles
because at the moment people who drive
those vehicles whatever models they may
be won't have a problem getting fuel and
i'm sure there's more of those cars on
the road at the moment and now with the
climate crisis we're only weeks away
from cot 26 actually the huge climate
crisis conference that's taking place in
glasgow where world leaders will discuss
how to um get to net zero emissions how
to keep global warming under 1.5 degrees
and also fulfill those sustainable
development goals that around climate
change and of course keeping global
warming as i said under 1.5 degrees now
the conservatives do have a plan in
place
to try and do that across the country
now there is some backlash i guess from
some conservative mps that are saying
this isn't as big an emergency as
perhaps we're making out now some uh
people are calling for as drastic action
that we had over coveted that i have
emergency legislation and really go for
goals when it comes to the climate
crisis but at this time where we are
seeing few bills going up when we're
seeing at the universal credit uplift
going away when we're seeing inflation
and food prices going up it's going to
be very hard to sell to the electorate
things like retrofitting boilers and
insulating our homes which actually are
going to be at the cost to us and not
just the government it's going to be
hard to push those plans through a time
where household bills are going up so
the government really does need to nail
its plan on what it's going to do and to
keep emissions down to keep co2
emissions down and to keep the earth um
from warming more than 1.5 degrees and
it is something that the government are
going to need for money into not just
when it comes to things like i said
retrofitting boilers insulating our
homes but also creating the
infrastructure that we need up and down
the country to support things like more
electric vehicles greener shipping
making last mile travel greener as well
there's a lot to be done and with only
four weeks to cop 26. the conservative
party really need to pull up their socks
get a succinct climate plan together oh
it's uh it's interesting it i would i do
wonder whether this situation because
obviously we're all looking at electric
vehicles and things now because the
phasing out of petrol and diesel whether
this has been a bit of a kick up the
rear for for quite a lot of us at the
moment which i have to say um
talking about the increased cost of
things uh though thomas and i said
paying for boils on people struggling um
the sunday mirrors got a story about
what i mean we tend to forget if we're
not living in one of these flats
affected by the cladding situation then
it sort of gone off our agenda a bit but
this this awful story about tom mansell
who's taking his own life
that's right i mean it's over four years
now since grand fall tar tragedy that
was june 2017 and and that this crisis
of cladding is still terrorizing scores
of people particularly in london it's
estimated right three million people are
still living in in far-risk flats and
for some of those people they're facing
i mean they're facing bills of an
astronomical nature some of them up to
200 000 pounds per household 200 000
pounds per household imagine just having
the weight of that hanging over you you
know so these homes are essentially
worthless they can't be sold um and
you have rising insurance bills so every
year you're actually seeing those bills
go up and up and up and you can't get
rid of this home that you're in this
this article is cataloging some of them
the crushing mental health effects that
this is having on residents of some of
these flats including you said tom
mansell who who who took his own life
last year he owned four flats and for at
least one of them anyway was facing
bills of over 50 000 pints with the
other three something similar to that
the total cost here is is simply
astounding so the development of 200
flats in which one of tom's flats was
situated the total bill
in order to redo the cladding is over 11
million pounds
and somebody has to pay for that and the
problem is that you've got you know
companies are saying well
why are we necessarily paying for it
this is government regulation that says
we have to change it you've got
leaseholders or the people renting are
only these flats who clearly don't have
that kind of money to hand who you would
and then you've also got the government
in a difficult position because you know
that's an awful lot of money to be
coughing up across the board to
universally pay for it so you know
somebody needs to pay for for some of
this and all the while you have
residents in every single one of these
flats not only living under the crushing
weights of those bills but also the
constant knowledge that their tar block
could be the next grenfell i mean it's
harrowing stuff
yeah yeah look if you're in that
situation
i mean the i think what you need to bear
in mind there are lots of people you can
call but if you're really struggling
with your mental health one one six one
two three is a number for the samaritans
where you can talk to them it's free
it's absolutely confidential no judgment
talk to them
uh if you if you you know finding
yourself really struggling um
breaks my heart
um to the sunday times aphea looking at
um schools opening on saturday i can
hear the size now from
teachers and students yes
from my daughter in particular and now
this school could open on saturdays as
135 000 pupils disappear so we could see
the school day extended perhaps from 8
00 am to 6 p.m or like i said schools
opening on saturday to try and encourage
the 135 000 people who haven't gone back
to school after schools closed for most
people's during the pandemic now there's
various reasons why these pupils have
quite aren't quite disappeared some of
them are being home schooled some of
them are too anxious and depressed and
waiting for mental health assessments to
go back to school and unfortunately
there's others who've been lost to
county lines gangs there's quite a few
issues at play here when we talk about
at this point unquote lost generation i
don't really like calling them that but
those fears that they could be a lost
generation because if they don't get
back into school in the way that they
should be that's going to affect their
life chances later on in life so these
extra classes if you will which could
take place after school or on saturdays
could include things like art and music
as well as the core subject math and
english
to encourage pupils to come back into
school and environment
where they feel safe and also to get
their learning back to where it should
be and you know the past 18 months or so
have been a really tough time for all
our pupils whatever age they are for
having so long out of school or kids
that did go to school while their
parents key workers having smaller class
sizes and having to adjust with learning
with children of different ages you know
it's been tough on pupils and teachers
alike and with 91 of people's back to
school that's great but we do have this
9
or 135 000 pupils as i said who seem to
have been lost and whatever that reason
is it feels like it's the real shame
some of them have been are being
homeschooled their parents have made
that decision and there's lots of
children on um waiting lists for mental
health assessments as well which is a
real shame and of course children who
are lost to county lines gangs we have
to get them back into school as well an
intern education setting that's going to
be beneficial for them and contribute to
their life chances later on in life
absolutely look to the observer thomas
scammers
that's right this figure astounded me so
the first half of this year alone first
half of this year alone
355 million pounds has been lost in
authorized push payment fraud so that's
where people transfer money to
fraudsters i mean clearly they don't
know it's fraudsters but they do do it
voluntarily this article talks quite a
lot about one of these types of fraud
it's about social engineering fraud so
you know quite a lot of the fraud that
we're used to is the kind of maybe you
see in your junk mail it's those
phishing emails those are particularly
sinister because they're designed to
capture people who are very vulnerable
who'll miss some of the obvious signs
you know it's littered with spelling
mistakes of the email the email address
from which it originated looks dodgy
they're designed to capture vulnerable
people this article is about a different
type of broad it's about social
engineering fraud
it's it's written by hillary osborne and
she talks to a number of cyber security
experts and some of the stuff that they
reveal about her is terrifying they were
able to find out from um osborne's
social media online huge amounts of
information about her pictures of her
cat what she did during her school lunch
times where she worked her kind of
day-to-day schedule pretty much where
she lived
this type of fraud is premeditated it's
targeted it's normally when a fraudster
maybe has got lucky and finds a
particularly sensitive piece of
information about it you know what tommy
we're out of time it's scary stuff good
to talk to you both
[Music]